[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
novembre 2022 à Villeneuve pile poil de
l'autre côté du lac il existe depuis peu
une manufacture céramique dans cette
manufacture il y a 5 personnes 5 potes
qui travaillent d'arrache-pied
en 2022 on a utilisé plus de 10 tonnes
d'argile pour produire plus de 10000
Jars magiques
pour en arriver là on est passé par des
hauts des bas des moments de célébration
des engueulades bref loin d'être un long
fleuve tranquille et c'est ça que j'ai
envie de vous raconter aujourd'hui c'est
ce projet on s'est relevé à chaque fois
on a fait preuve de résilience on s'est
régénéré voici l'histoire de deux potes
étudiants qui ont fait de leur projet
leur métier septembre 2013 rentrée
universitaire et je rencontre très vite
Clément autre fondateur du projet et on
a un délire ensemble c'est le soir sur
le canapé d'inventer des trucs de créer
des idées des concepts bref plein de
choses
avril 2014
on assiste en tant que spectateur un
concours de pitch si finalistes
avec à la clé 30.000 francs
en ressort de cette soirée avec des
étoiles dans les yeux et on se dit que
dans quelques années c'est à nous de
pitcher notre idée septembre 2017 ça y
est on s'inscrit on se lance mais là
plus du tout aucune idée
alors on décide de se reconcentrer et
d'avoir une vision plus sur le long
terme un message qui nous porte et là
c'est beaucoup plus facile
avoir un impact positif sur la planète
on décide alors de re-végétaliser les
villes et on part sur un potager urbain
vertical autonome que vous avez
fonctionné en fonction de vos box bref
une catastrophe hyper galère mais
on intègre un système d'irrigation
millénaire appelé
Oya j'ouvre une parenthèse
est une jarre en céramique qui permet
d'irriguer les plantes
il suffit de la planter dans la terre
de la remplir d'eau et de laisser la
magie opérer
par capillarité le se diffuse
naturellement
ce qui permet donc aux plantes de
s'autoréguler selon leur propre besoin
permet d'économiser jusqu'à 70% d'eau de
n'avoir aucun stress hydrique et surtout
une autonomie qui peut aller jusqu'à 10
jours je ferme la parenthèse et vous
savez désormais c'est qui noya
novembre 2017 on part donc à la
recherche d'un producteur de
premier problème c'est un produit qui
n'existe quasiment pas
de fil en aiguille on trouve un
producteur en France qui accepte d'une
rencontre
12 heures de voiture plus tradant la
même journée et après un rendez-vous et
Inaya offerte on est super content
avril 2018 on est en finale objectif
atteint yes et là on a une idée farfelue
avec Clément
c'est de faire un rap pendant la finale
en arrivant au final
devant 300 personnes
on fait notre rap
et ce jour-là on en prend on apprend
quelque chose
c'est qu'on n'est pas fait pour le rap
ce concours on le remportera pas mais on
a tellement aimé ce petit projet
entrepreneurial à côté de nos études
qu'on décide de continuer
été 2018 j'invite Clément chez mes
parents dans la campagne et on crée un
nouveau business plan et cette fois-ci
on se focalise uniquement sur les Zoya
on repart donc à la recherche des
producteurs et en décide d'être
finalement revendeur de sesoyas en
Suisse
septembre 2018
on rentre en master
et on a un objectif très clair
en six mois
on doit commercialiser nos premières
Zoya
nouveau problème
plus aucune nouvelle de nos copains
français
c'est pas grave
on décide de gérer tout de A à Z
nouveau défi
on est ni céramiste et encore moins
jardinier
on décide alors de contacter tous les
services possibles pour produire nos
oyats et on a une première opportunité
les ateliers protégés j'ouvre une
nouvelle parenthèse
les ateliers protégés permettent à des
personnes en déficience physique et ou
mentales d'avoir un emploi
super on se dit ça englobe parfaitement
avec notre message d'avoir un impact
donc on sait où produire
mais quoi quelle forme et la rebelote
on contacte à nouveau un maximum de
designers pour avoir nos premières
formes
et là on trouve la perle rare elle nous
design de trois premières formes
on crée ensuite notre premier site qu'on
fait nous-mêmes avec Clément toujours
sur le canapé
mars 2019
on commercialise nos trois premières
le début de la galère
on pensait que les gens allaient acheter
une à chaque fois donc
on se dit qu'on va acheter des cartons
unitaires petite taille on en achète une
grosse quantité
et là
on se rend compte que les gens achètent
plutôt trois quatre y a à chaque fois
ce problème vient du fait que Clément on
était colocataire à l'époque qu'on avait
un petit appart
et donc cette masse de carton est restée
pendant des années dans sa chambre
à ce moment-là nos premières ventes
c'est nos mamans nos cousins nos potes
et un soir 22h BIM la petite
notification on ne connaissait pas la
première personne première vente
officielle
[Applaudissements]
mars 2020
donc tout le monde rentre chez soi et
les gens découvrent ou redécouvrent le
jardinage
et achète sur internet donc le marché de
la jardinerie fait X2 et les e-commerce
font X5 donc nous on fait x 10
bonne nouvelle
mais devinez quoi
les ateliers protégés ferment bien
évidemment
OK
on décide de nous-mêmes produire
on part donc dans le garage des parents
de Clément à Saint cernes au-dessus de
Nyon dans la montagne on prend la
céramiste des ateliers protégés avec
nous et on fait notre première
production
mais fallait les cuire ces
on trouve un four à Vevey
la céramique c'est assez fragile
quand les packs c'est une catastrophe
donc je vous laisse imaginer
les allers-retours de Saint Cergues dans
la montagne jusqu'à Vevey pour produire
on récupère pas beaucoup de pièces
juillet 2019
on arrive à acquérir notre premier local
de 35 mètres carrés on investit aussi
dans un four d'occasion de sac
et on a nos premiers partenariats
on a jusqu'à 12 semaines de retard son
eau livraison
décembre 2020 on est contacté par des
plus grands jardineries
janvier 2021 on refait un business plan
cette fois-ci on se focalise sur la
production on veut créer un stock tampon
et on passe trois jours par semaine à la
production tout en gérant le master si
jamais on rentre aussi en contact avec
des investisseurs
juillet 2021
on a huit semaines de retard c'est mieux
mais peut mieux faire vous êtes d'accord
août 2021
on finalise et on réussit nos études
novembre 2021 on signe avec les
investisseurs et on s'installe dans
cette fameuse manufacture à Villeneuve
on se met enfin à 100% dans ce projet
décembre 2021 on intègre Pauline comme
associé et chef de production Pauline
elle a plus de 10 ans d'expérience dans
l'industrie française avec des
industries de plus de 2000 personnes je
me dis qu'à 4 ça devrait le faire
février 2022 on recrute pour augmenter
la production on fait de la céramique on
se dit qu'on va recruter des céramistes
comme vous l'aurez fait j'imagine pas du
tout
les services sont des créateurs
nous on a un geste qui est très
répétitif sur les trois personnes il y
en a une seule qui va rester et pour la
petite anecdote elle avait aucune
expérience dans la céramique
mars 2022
il y a très peu de rapports
scientifiques sur les oyats on sait que
ça marche par la capillarité mais c'est
tout
on décide donc d'intégrer un biologiste
dans notre projet pour optimiser notre
produit
à ce même moment période de mars
la haute saison arrive
notre fournisseur d'argile nous appelle
pour nous dire
rupture de stock j'ai plus de terre pour
cette année ok c'est pas grave
on appelle tous les fournisseurs
d'Europe je les connais tous
et là on reçoit des dizaines et des
dizaines d'échantillons on les teste on
les reteste pour au bout de 6 semaines
avoir une nouvelle terre qui correspond
même mieux à notre produit elle provient
d'Allemagne on relance la production
mais 2022
on est lauréat du prix suisse de
l'éthique c'est notre premier titre et
on espère pas le dernier
juillet 2022
on tient nos délais 15 jours de
livraison max mais plus de stock
septembre 2022
on décide d'aller plus loin on invite
dans un nouveau four à céramique un peu
plus gros et on se dit allons en Suisse
à les maniques
mail téléphone classique aucune réponse
alors nous l'allemand on y connaît
vraiment rien le suisse allemand j'ai
pas envie d'en parler
c'est pas grave Clément décide d'aller
sur Zurich et pendant une semaine il va
à la rencontre de tous les responsables
de jardinerie à faire à suivre
novembre 2022
on a une manufacture qui tourne à 200%
avec une équipe sur motivée et un
objectif très clair aujourd'hui on peut
irriguer un mètre carré demain notre
projet veut aller irriguer jusqu'à un
hectare pour implémenter cette solution
dans les milieux les plus arides du
monde
et moi je suis là devant vous avec le
même mantra
avoir un impact positif sur la planète
et je kiffe
et pourquoi je kiffe parce que j'ai
essayé je me suis loupé j'ai appris et
finalement
je me régénère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]